Tracy is putting out
decorative bowls of potpourri
in each room of the
hotel where she works.
She wants to fill each bowl
with 1/5 of a can of potpourri.
If Tracy has 4 cans of
potpourri, in how many rooms
can she place a
bowl of potpourri?
So she has 4 cans, and
she wants to divide this 4
cans into groups
of 1/5 of a can.
So if you have 4 of
something and you're
trying to divide it into
groups of a certain amount,
you would divide by
that amount per group.
So you want to divide 4 by 1/5.
You want to divide 4 cans of
potpourri into groups of 1/5.
So let's visualize this.
Let me draw one can of
potpourri right over here.
So one can of potpourri can
clearly be cut up into 5/5.
We have it right over here.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So 1 can of potpourri
can fill 5 bowls
if you put 1/5 in each bowl.
Now, we have 4 cans.
So let me paste these.
So 2, 3, and 4.
So how many total bowls of
potpourri can Tracy fill?
Well, she's got 4 cans.
So this is going to
be equal to-- let
me do this is the right
color-- this is going
to be equal to, once
again, she has 4 cans.
And then for each
of those cans, she
can fill 5 bowls of potpourri
because each bowl only
requires a 1/5 of those cans.
So this is going to be the
same thing as 4 times 5.
Or we can even write
this as 4 times 5 over 1.
5 is the same
thing as 5/1, which
is the same thing
as 4 times 5, which,
of course, is equal to 20.
She can fill 20 cans-- or I
should say, with her 4 cans,
she can fill 20
bowls of potpourri.
Now, just as a
review here, we've
already seen that
dividing by a number
is equal to multiplying
by its reciprocal.
And we see that right over here.
Dividing by 1/5
is the same thing
as multiplying by the
reciprocal of 1/5, which is 5/1.
So she could fill up
20 bowls of potpourri.